deux fois par semaine david suit un
cours d'échecs à distance avec la numéro
un française
s'il est encore trop jeune pour être
promis à un avenir professionnel
il a des qualités plutôt rare pour son
âge que potence et les enfants jamais
vraiment savoir prédire s'assure qu'il a
beaucoup de qualités inhérentes aux
échecs et les compétiteurs et les
passions les médicale plus qu'un jeu les
échecs permettent aussi de stimuler et
canaliser cet enfant à haut potentiel
c'est comme un sport de compétition
c'est pas comme si je jouais un autre
jeu comme avec mes amis aussi plus c'est
plus
ça vaut plus de choses pour moi david a
découvert les échecs en se rendant avec
son père aux championnats de france à
chartres il ya deux ans on a fait
vraiment au championnat et et j'étais
moi même en tant que pédagogue et
adultes impressionné par sa patience
lanville envie d'y retourner et donc à
partir de là l'aventuré a commencé on
appelle quand je vois mon fils est
heureux et épanoui et on a envie d'aller
d'aller de l'avant tout simplement en
plus de lui faire répéter des exercices
son père l'emmène à différents tournois
david vient d'ailleurs de remporter le
titre de champion de france des moins de
dix ans et sept coupes énormes je suis
fier mais
et bah je suis quand j'ai vu la coupe et
je me suis dit mais c'est pas une coupe
ça c'est un saxophone lamont mobility
phb à 6
ces deux décès de re
le titre et après d'aller au championnat
d'heure
en attendant il s'adonne à ses autres
passions le tennis le volley la natation
mais aussi le piano
[Musique]